girl you're looking fine man girl hmm
come here girl oh god you're ugly wait
did senpai say hi to me you know you
shouldn't smoke outside a hospital
especially if you're pregnant do you
know how inconsiderate it is to smoke
when you're pregnant goddamnit have some
thought for your baby I gotta see how
they just study here that idea we can't
really do [ __ ]
she smells too oh god the cats I am in
again
oh no oh my god oh my god a free car
thank you haha thanks I goddamn it what
are you doing yes yes yes yes oh [ __ ]
better use my super ability you'll never
catch me now camps Oh God
[Music]
all right I need a ride out of this
[ __ ] dump yes I'm the king now I can
stop the impossible tears ah hey
why oh [ __ ] sorry oh that's my cab
it looks like he's giving me a [ __ ]
take me to the ocean yes they're just
not what I asked for
hyung stay water Pudge the water keep
waving keep spinning
unsure what destroy their watch god damn
it oh there we go
you can never catch me
[Music]
never come up a set [ __ ]
this is this plane even fly bro come on
lift god dammit
laughs sorry
actually I'm I need milk this is pretty
convenient those are a little small but
I can bark with that I might as well get
a haircut let's see what you I don't
have any money but I can pay you with my
eyebrows get in that's not a
piece-of-shit plane I hate you you ruin
my life
get in what the [ __ ] is that that's not
how you get in the plane now get in
please I said [ __ ] the police not god
damn it well oh nevermind alright this
doesn't work I swear to god I'll get
aids in my ass come on a house oh I
can't [ __ ] lie hey hug I get it I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it
okay thank you don't want a hug okay
where are we
my god am not the cops oh they're not
after me what's that [ __ ] are they doing
[ __ ] later noobs Hey
oh god why is my plane on fire uh I'm
sure it's nothing
Oh God Oh God just land safely can do it
to ya how you doing there parents now
we're talking baby
where are we going no one knows why does
everyone have to be in my way that's a
big hot
let's see if we can land on that train
yes
no all right that tried escaping maybe a
lot too fast maybe a long floppy okay
let's make it yeah I'm actually fine
they call me the mountain goat for no
reason
actually for a reason wait no just me
senpai senpai what's so scary about a
man that can jump jump i hey senpai
we can be together ha ha ha ha TenPoint
simple man you got quite the muscle lady
Wow
[Music]
you know I exercise myself like no this
means my goddamned yes yes I got you now
chef Ivan I got you I said I got you
[ __ ] listen [ __ ] senpai don't
worry pills is here and he's here to
save your life what the bouzouki up your
eyes hey she looks pretty hot Sam pies
at you oh my god Sam pie you're a man
nope jump attack Wow jump attack failed
look at that little gay couple that
you're cured I give up I give up
here's one caps zero please don't
explode got it
no problem no problem thing okay there's
a slide problem we're fine what's with
this [ __ ] psycho oh god oh god
okay we're fine some people say brolo I
say yo nice Jenna yes yes No
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
watch out I told it watch out okay
this doesn't work I don't even know life
anymore oh my god I know life no dance
me ah I miss sampai alright Fred's gonna
have to end this episode here maybe like
I've been doing watching let me know if
you want more GTA hits the sky come with
a icy breath and the next one that's
only a awesome love you
[Music]
let's try and make a friend let's be
smoothie err okay just friends nothing
more hello hi the hell is wrong with our
face the hell is wrong with her face
what's up with you girl she just changed
direction that she thought yeah and you
know you see him just walk away
senpai did she notice me senpai notice
me senpai don't joke I run away from my
senpai
oh I'm coming here hello senpai runs oh
[ __ ] temp I'm so sorry I was gonna hug
you I swear to God oh wow